The correct answer is--you should be looking at the HTTP request.
I'll try it myself--okay--we have our form, I click submit,
and--boom--here we are.
This is actually--what we're looking at--is the HTTP request.
We'll look at the code in a sec to remind ourselves how all of this happened.
But do you remember from our first lesson when we talked about
HTTP requests and how they look?
Well--here's our request line--
GET--and then our URL--/testform,
and then q equals the text we typed in the field.
You can see a couple more headers,
Accept and what languages we are expecting to receive--
what character sets are okay.
We can see the host header--we're familiar with that one.
You can see the referer header--referer header is interesting.
This refers to the URL that sent this request.
So--the URL of our form is localhost8080/
and the URL we're on right now is /testform,
but this header is helpful for telling the server where the request came from.
You'll notice that referer is misspelled here,
that's because in the original HTTP spec
the word referrer was spelled wrong. It normally has two Rs.
But it's lived on for backwards compatibility reasons,
for nearly 20 years now.
And--this is actually symptomatic of how a lot of things
in HTTP or on the web are, which is--you know--
somebody made a decision--you know--20 years ago
that still haunts us today,
and it's not necessarily a bad thing, it's just
a side effect of when things grow organically over time.
Another header we've talked about--our user agent--
in this case I'm using Chrome--you can see that here--
amidst a bunch of version information on Mac OSX.
Looking at our code--here's what we did.
We set the content type to text plain.
If we hadn't done that, the response we were looking at in HTML,
or in the browser would have looked weird,
because the browser would have assumed it was HTML,
and a lot of that text wouldn't have shown up.
So, we set it to plain because I knew what we were going to do.
Then instead of writing text or writing out our q parameter,
we actually wrote out this request object itself,
which is the Python object that represents the request,
but conveniently it prints out very much like HTTP looks,
which is not a coincidence.
So--it's a handy little tool though when you're writing web applications
and debugging, you want to see--you know--where something broke
or what's going on, you can just print out the request and see.
So--let's replace these two lines again, back to the way they were,
and move on to something else.
I'm just going to comment these lines out, however,
because we're going to need them for later.
So--this is how our file was before, let's move on to a new section.